for a store near you.
>> Laura: WOW, IT'S A BIG NOSE
RATTLING WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS OFFICIALLY
INVESTIGATING WHETHER THE FBI OR
THE DOJ BROKE LAWS WHEN IT USED
PFIZER WARNS TO SPY ON AN
AMERICAN NEWS INVESTIGATION,
MOST LIKELY CARTER PAGE.
REVERSE LEARNED OF THIS WHEN THE
HOUSE AND TALK MANY MEMOS
DECLASSIFIED, IT DETAILS HOW THE
FBI USED AN UNVERIFIED DOSSIER
FUNDED BY THE DEMOCRATS TO SPY
ON MR. PAGE.
I'VE LONG SO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS KEY TO
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENED HERE, AND TO
DISCUSS FURTHER, LET'S BRING IN
BOB GOODLATTE, REPUBLICAN FROM
VIRGINIA, HERE REPORTING ON
THAT, BYRON YORK, CHIEF
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
BIG NEWS TONIGHT, CONGRESSMAN
GOODLATTE, THERE HAS BEEN
STONEWALLING TAKING PLACE FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS.
3 MILLION OR 1.2 MILLION
DOCUMENTS, YOU'VE GOT 3,000
DOCUMENTS.
MAYBE IT'S JUST TOO MANY
DOCUMENTS YOU WANT.
MAYBE THE COPY MACHINE IS
BROKEN.
WHAT IS THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THIS DELAY?
>> WELL, THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT
HAVE A GOOD JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE DELAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI,
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, HAVE BOTH
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TO ME.
THEY NOW SAY THEY ARE HARD AT
WORK GETTING THOSE DOCUMENTS
READY FOR US.
THE REQUIREMENT OF THE SUBPOENA
THAT I ISSUED LAST THURSDAY IS
THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS GET TO US
BY NEXT THURSDAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE PLEASED
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WILL ALSO LOOK
INTO THIS MATTER.
BUT TWO THINGS.
ONE, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL CAN'T
LOOK AT IT FROM THE SAME
PERSPECTIVE THAT CONGRESS CAN OR
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE THAT AN
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL COUNSEL CAN.
AND SECONDLY, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SHOULD GET OUT
HIS REPORT WITH REGARD TO THE
INVESTIGATION HE HAS BEEN
CONDUCTING FOR THE PAST YEAR
WITH REGARD TO HOW THE FBI HAS
HANDLED THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION FIRST.
WE NEED THAT INFORMATION OUT
NOW.
THEN HE CAN GO ON AND LOOK AT
THE OTHER MATTER.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE NEED THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WE HAVE
SUBPOENAED.
>> Laura: BYRON, I WANT TO GO
TO YOU ON THIS.
JEFF SESSIONS HAS KIND OF COME
AROUND ON THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON -- THIS
RIGMAROLE, AS MY MOTHER USED TO
SAY, HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME.
>> VERY LITTLE TRUST GOING ON,
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON A
LONG TIME.
REMEMBER PAUL RYAN SAID THE FBI
WAS STONEWALLING TO HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MONTHS
AND MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO.
>> Laura: WHY DOES
JEFF SESSIONS NOW SEE IT AS A
PROBLEM?
>> I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
YOU KNOW THE TEXTS BETWEEN LISA
STRZOK
AND CARTER PAGE, SAYING THEY
WERE HAVING
AN AFFAIR, WE HAD TO REJECT THE
PERSONAL STUFF, WELL, A COUPLE
OF MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAD BEEN
GOING OVER AND LOOKING AT FULLER
VERSIONS AND FINDING OUT THAT
SOME ACTUAL REAL OFFICIAL
MATERIAL EVIDENCE WAS LEFT OUT
OF THOSE, WAS REDACTED, SO THERE
WAS ZERO TRUSTS THERE, AND I
THINK THE FACT THAT THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS SENDING
PEOPLE OVER TO LOOK AT THIS
STUFF HAS PROBABLY TOLD THE FBI
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE UP.
>> Laura: CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THESE TEXTS
AND "NEWS TONIGHT" BROKE THAT
DENIS McDONOUGH, OF COURSE,
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR BARACK OBAMA, WAS MENTIONED,
AND AT LEAST ONE, LOOKS LIKE
MORE, TEXTS BETWEEN STRZOK AND
PAGE, AND I GUESS THE CONCERN
IS, WHAT?
THE CONCERN IS THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS NOT JUST KEPT ABREAST OF
THIS INVESTIGATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, BUT YOU SEE IT ONLINE,
PEOPLE WERE WONDERING, WERE THEY
DIRECTING IT?
IF SO, THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
>> IT IS A VERY BIG PROBLEM.
WE ARE NOT PASSING JUDGMENT ON
THAT AT THAT POINT, BUT YOU
CAN'T MAKE A DECISION IN THE
CONGRESS ABOUT WHAT IS MATERIAL
OVER AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
WE KNOW THAT PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE WERE TALKING BY THE
FEDERAL PAGE WHO WAS APPOINTED
TO THE FISA COURT AND MR. STRZOK
SAID, OH, HE'S A FRIEND OF MINE,
I'M GOING TO MEET WITH HIM.
WE DON'T KNOW IF ANYTHING WRONG
TOOK PLACE IN WHATEVER MEETING
THEY HAD, BUT THAT WAS MATERIAL
THAT WAS WITHHELD FROM US BY
REDACTED MATERIALS.
WE NEED THE UNREDACTED MATERIAL.
>> Laura: THERE ARE TOO MANY
INSTANCES OF EITHER AN
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT,
PERHAPS AN ACTUAL CONFLICT,
POLITICAL AFFILIATION GOING BACK
TO HILLARY OR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND NOW THIS.
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A F
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A I
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A N
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A D
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A O
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A F
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A P
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A I
CONTRARY        CONTRERAS IS A E
AND STRZOK.
I'M TELLING YOU, THIS GIVES
EVERYBODY A SENSE THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE BEGINNING
WAS THE INSURANCE POLICY, WAS AN
INSURANCE POLICY IN THE FALL OF
2016, HEAVEN FORBID, SHOULD
SOMETHING HAPPEN WITH HILLARY,
MAYBE HER HEALTH, OR WHO KNOWS,
MAYBE DONALD TRUMP WAS GOING TO
WIN EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN'T
THINK THEY WOULD COME UP BECAUSE
WHEN YOU SEE DENNIS McDONOUGH
ON THOSE TEXTS?
>> A LOT OF THEM THOUGHT
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS, THAN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL COOPERATE WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS, AND